- Good night.
No, uh...
Good night.
Bonne nuit, Trick.
Bonne nuit--
- [gasps]
What are you doing?
- What are you doing?
both:
Where--
- Where are you going?
- Just gonna go say
good night to Trick,
see if he needs anything
before bed.
Where are you going?
- I was also gonna go...
see if he needed
to be put to bed.
- Ass before class.
Hey, Trick.
- Hey.
- Books, nice.
I've read about those.
- Cool.
-Just wanted to come
say good night.
Thinking about turning in.
Unless I stay up to,
I don't know, have sex.
- Okay, night, night.
- Oh...okay.
[scoffs]
Good luck in there.
There's jizz
all over the walls.
[spits]
- No.
My hand.
[slurring]
Good night, Trick.
- Excuse me?
[pop music playing]
[phone buzzing]
- You touching yourself
to porno?
- No, Gene,
I'm not watching porno.
- Yeah, me neither.
Who watches porno?
What is that, the "Labyrinth"
in the background?
You watching the "Labyrinth?"
- No, it's not the "Labyrinth."
It's--I don't need to watch
the "Labyrinth" to fall asleep.
It's a different movie.
Go to sleep.
- Nicholas Cage?
Oh, Dickolas Cage.
That makes more sense.
[eerie demonic laughter]
[dreamy music]
♪ ♪
- ♪ Today I found her ♪
♪ We're so meant to be ♪
♪ The only question,
would she marry me? ♪
♪ 'Cause if she does ♪
♪ All the people
of Earth will talk ♪
♪ They'll say ♪
♪ It's Trick and Billie ♪
♪ Look at those two ♪
♪ I know we're silly ♪
♪ Can I get a pic of you? ♪
♪ ♪
♪ The people of Earth ♪
♪ Will talk ♪
♪ ♪
[dreamy shimmering]
- Harder!
Ah, harder!
[Trick yelling]
Jay Baruchel!
- Oh, so sorry, Jay!
Jay, oh, Baruchel!
- Whoo, Canada!